Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Es ist März. Wir stehen vor dem Salon, um heute den Untergang zu begleiten, so würde ich sagen.
Welchen Untergang denn genau?
Trumps.
Ist dieses Buch das Ergebnis des Untergangs oder ist das Buch das Plädoyer für den Untergang? Ist das Buch eine Gebrauchsanweisung für den Untergang? Oder würdest du sagen, dieses Buch ist geschrieben gegen Donald Trump?
Nein. Alex Karp hat ein Buch geschrieben mit einer Idee, die er gerne verwirklicht sehen möchte, von Donald Trump.
Ja.
Und wir sehen jetzt, dass nicht nur wir finden, dass Donald Trump dumm ist, sondern dass Alex Karp wahrscheinlich auch gerade die Hände über die Köpfe zusammenschlägt. Nicht nur seine, sondern auch Petatils Kopf. Wir lesen sehr viel Petatilideologie in diesem Buch. Und man sieht die Idee und man sieht den Ansatz. Aber wie es nun mal so ist, man schickt die Achtjährigen auf die Strecke. Sie sollen so schnell laufen, wie sie können. Sie verlassen ihre Bahn. Sie stolpern über ihre eigenen Füße und am Ende kommt niemand ins Ziel. Und dieses Buch dokumentiert es, finde ich, wenn man es klug und inspirativ liest, auf wirklich sehr eindrückliche Art und Weise.
Ja, ich hab's noch mal anders gelesen. Also du hast vollkommen recht, nämlich in der Hinsicht, dass ich dachte, ja, die Milliardäre, man hört es immer wieder, wollen Opernhäuser bauen oder Tunnel durch die Alpen bohren oder einfach nur irgendwelche Superjachten besitzen. Und ich denke immer, das ist schlimm, aber es geht auch viel schlimmer, nämlich so, wie Alex Karp sich das ausdenkt. In gewisser Weise ist es das erschreckendste Buch, das wir im Salon je gelesen haben. Also ich bin wirklich schockiert darüber, finde es aber absolut zeitgemäß. Ich glaube, es knüpft einen so viel an, dass ich erstaunt war beim Lesen, aber ich habe mich selten so gegruselt, auch weil es in einer fast argumentativen Redlichkeit erst einmal so tut, als sei das doch das, was der gesunde Menschenverstand so wollen mag. Und das ist ein wirklich erschreckendes Buch. Von daher bin ich ja froh, es gibt auch, wie ich hier sehe, auch noch andere Bücher zu lesen, die optimistischer sind oder der Titel Die Kinderwüste. Dein Buch ist jetzt erschienen.
Heute ist Erscheinungstermin. Du kriegst es natürlich vom Autor persönlich über dich.
Dankeschön, danke.
Denn die Kiste von Hoffmann & Crump ist auch bei mir jetzt endlich angekommen. Das letzte Buch, das ich hatte, war ja ein Diebstahl von mir, von der Signieraktion. Ich habe mir einfach einen oder Umschlag so ein bisschen kaputt war mitgenommen. Jetzt ist es da. Es ist, du hast ja schon betont, am Ende geht es auch um Weltpolitik. Es geht die ganze Zeit um die Verklammerung kleiner und großer Politik. Ich beginne mit Dunja Hayali und sage, man kann nicht im heutigen Teil stehen und sagen der Staatshaushalt, jeder, der einen Haushalt führt, weiß ja, woran es jetzt mangelt. Nein, diese Verknüpfung gibt es nicht. Und die Verknüpfung sind anders. Ich stelle da, wie die Politik immer auf die Familie zu sprechen kommt, aber nie auf die Familie, sondern immer auf das ideale Bild der Pastorenfamilie, weil man so auch den Staat organisiert, helft den Nachbarn, achte auf Oma und Opa und so weiter und so fort. Also die Floskeln sind ja alle da, nur es passt immer nie. Und am Ende das große Finale natürlich, was ist mit China und Russland? Dort gibt es auch feministische Politik, feministische, akademische Politikberatung und so weiter, weil auch in China 600 Millionen Frauen leben, die sich das nicht einfach, also die nicht einfach, nicht mal in China tun, wie ihnen gesagt wird. Und der amerikanische Versuch jetzt den Frauen zu sagen, wo es langgeht, wird natürlich, also wird man halt diskutieren, platzt gerade in der Hinsicht, es ist kein Buch über Gedöns, es gibt genug Bücher über die Gefühlichkeit von Familie und wie erziehe ich meine Kinder und wie bringe ich sie zum Schlafen und was ist, wenn sie Piki-Ita sind, sondern es gibt andere Dimensionen. Und ich habe ja beim letzten Mal schon bemerkt, wie schnell sich Debatten drehen. Ja. Im September 2022 kam die Altenrepublik, damals war der Fachkräftemangel noch ein, oh, das ist ja so eine Industrieideologie und heute wissen wir, nein, wir diskutieren anders darüber. Und wir haben es jetzt gerade diese Woche gesehen, wie Friedrich Merz noch im Fernsehen sitzt und sagt, Verschuldung niemals, Frau Meisperger in dem Fall, auch in diesem Studio sitzen junge Leute, den können wir jetzt nicht sagen, dass wir deren Geld schon mal ausgeben müssen. Und eine Woche später tut er genau das. Wird das Vorzeichen einmal komplett umgedreht.
Und zwar richtig kräftig.
Wie es sich nicht mal die SPD getraut hat, im Wahlkampf zu sagen.
Ja, es stand nicht so im Wahlprogramm. Also die SPD ging ja in dem Wahlprogramm verglichen mit anderen relativ weit, aber das ist weit davon entfernt geblieben, was man jetzt gerade macht.
Von daher, der Ansatz meines Buches ist, wenn man es durchgelesen hat, 140 Seiten absolviert, schafft man auf einer Zugfahrt, dass man danach sagt, Familie, so geht es nicht weiter. Wir brauchen jetzt ein neues Vorzeichen. Es ist der große Systemstreit. Und alle mitten dritten.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, freue mich sehr. Der Untertitel, wie die Politik Familien im Stich lässt. Und da steckt natürlich auch die Aufforderung drin, dass die Politik das nicht mehr tun sollte. Aber erstmal sieht es düster aus.
Sehr düster. Ja. Wir haben ein Investitionsprogramm in Brücken, Pranzer, immerhin ein bisschen Schule. Wir wissen nicht genau, wie viel dann da hängen bleibt. Und gestern gab es ja eine Meldung, dass ein Bundesland jetzt gesagt hat, als zentrale Anordnung vier Unterrichtsstunden weniger pro Woche für alle Schüler als Beitrag für die Haushaltslage. Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen.
Nein, es ist katastrophal. Aber wir bleiben bei den katastrophalen Themen. Du hast wahrscheinlich auch dir Trump und Zelinsky angesehen. Wie wirkte das Ganze auf dich?
Ich schau mir jetzt alles gerne an, wo Trump auf dem letzten Loch pfeift. Wir haben sowas wie im Oval Office noch.
Hattest du den Eindruck, ja?
Also ich habe derzeit konstant nur den Eindruck.
Ja, das finde ich interessant. Ich habe den Eindruck nämlich nicht.
Also ich habe jetzt mehrfach, okay dann schildere ich erstmal meine Beobachtung. Ich habe jetzt mehrfach betont, dass sich Donald Trump bisher noch nicht zum Kongress getraut hat. Sondern er hat ihm einfach so ein Bill hingelegt, so ein Haushaltsgesetz. Und das ist One Beautiful Bill, wie es halt so heißt, in dem er alles mit einem Mal regeln will, weil er weiß, ich kann mich auf Streitereien dort nicht einlassen. Ich kriege nicht mal meinen eigenen Minister durch. Ich brauche JD. Vance, der dort einen Thai-Break, obwohl ich eine 3-Stimmen-Mehrheit habe, bricht, damit die Senatoren sagen, na gut, der RFK kann doch mal Gesundheitsminister werden, ne?
So.
Donald Trump ist jetzt zum Kongress gegangen. Es ist sozusagen der größtmögliche Auftritt, den ein amerikanischer Präsident haben kann. Den kann man aber nicht unendlich oft machen. Wir hatten nicht nur die Oval Office Situation mit Zelensky, sondern wir hatten auch die mit Kirstama, wo Kirstama meinte, ich habe hier ein Brief von His Majesty und so. Er lädt sie ein. Das gab es noch nie. Es ist der zweite Staatsbesuch für einen amerikanischen Präsidenten. Üblicherweise gibt es nur ein, das ist und so weiter. Ja. Also alles, was wir an Semantik erleben, ist das Maximum. Es lässt sich nicht noch mal toppen. Und wir sind erst im ersten Monat. Ja. Es muss aber immer weiter getoppt werden. Das ist das Programm. Also wo soll das hinführen? Es ist alles ausgereizt und die Bedrohungslage ist soweit auch ausgereizt. So. Und das sieht man insbesondere bei Zelensky.
Wenn wir jetzt auf dieses konkrete Treffen kommen, wie hat denn das auf dich gewirkt? Also hast du nur diese zehn Minuten gesehen oder diese 50 Minuten? Weil wenn man sich diese 50 Minuten ansieht, was ich auch erst dann viel später getan habe, dann bekommt man ja doch einen anderen Eindruck. Ich glaube, ich brauche jetzt hier keinen Disclaimer zu machen, dass ich zwar ein Blöd finde und ich das alles sehr verantwortungslos finde etc. Nur gab mir etwas zu denken und zwar Jochen Bittner von der Zeit, also ein Transatlantiker, ein Konservativer, jemand dessen Artikel ich jetzt nicht besonders schätze. Dessen Meinung aber dann ja doch mitunter, bei aller Kontraintuition für mich dann interessant ist, war auf Twitter zu lesen. Er schrieb dort oder auf X. Natürlich haben sich Trump und Vans vollkommen würdellos und autoritär gegenüber Zelensky und der Ukraine verhalten. Aber was ist in den ganzen 50 Minuten der Pressekonferenz passiert? Nicht nur in den letzten zehn Minuten. Und dann schreibt er, Zelensky hatte offenbar die Erwartung, dass die USA bei den Verhandlungen auf der Seite der Ukraine stehen, um Putin zu stoppen. Er ging davon aus, dass es keine Kompromisse bei Gebietsfragen geben könne und er wollte starke militärische Sicherheitsgarantien. Trump machte daraufhin noch einmal klar, was er seit langem sagt, dass er auf keiner Seite steht, sondern in der Mitte. Und das bedeutet bei den eigenen nationalen Interessen und so weiter. Diese Position war längst klar, schreibt Bittner. Und Zelensky hat aber nicht darauf entsprechend reagiert. Für ihn stellte das, und das sagt Bittner hier auch verständlicherweise, als Verrat da. Aber er sagt dann auch, der zweite Fehler von Zelensky war dann, dass er die ganze Politikmethode von Trump in Zweifel gezogen hat, indem er bestritt, dass man mit Putin Deals machen könne. So und ich hab mir dann darauf hin, also nur aufgrund dieses Tweets habe ich mir dann diese 50 Minuten angesehen und dachte, ja da hat der Bittner einen Punkt. Ja klar. Denn es war hochinteressant. Wir wissen ja, Trump ist unberechenbar, aber wir wissen auch in gewisser Weise, wie er tickt und was geht, was nicht geht. Also man kann zum Beispiel Donald Trump nicht unterbrechen. Das ist einfach verboten.
Man muss ihm einen Brief zeigen des Königs, der eine einmalige Einladung ausspricht und alles andere.
Ich sage nicht, dass ich das, also ist verständlich die Reaktion von, also direkt zutiefst menschlich die Reaktion von Silenz und all das. Nur, wenn ich gehe, nur strategisch blick ich darauf. Und dann denke ich, nee das ist keine gute Strategie. Trump beginnt diese Konferenz damit, dass er sagt, wir machen ein Deal, ich bin ein Deal-Maker, wir brauchen jetzt ein Ende dieses Sterbens etc. Und er hat mit Putin gesprochen und auch mit Präsident Silensky schonen und dass sie sich da einig werden und sowas. Also er verbreitet gute Stimmung. Daraufhin hat dann Silensky das Wort und sagt, ja also Putin ist ein Terrorist, Putin ist ein Killer. Kompromisse mit einem Killer, wie geht das? Das kann ich natürlich so sehen und das setzt einen auch moralisch auf die richtige Seite, nur strategisch gegenüber Trump, der gerade sagt, ich hab jetzt mal mit allen gesprochen und wir leiten da was ein, ist das natürlich maximal blöde. Und das hat ja auch dann dazu geführt, also und das schaukelte sich immer weiter hoch an. Ich würde jedem empfehlen, sich das mal ganz anzusehen. Natürlich ist das eine Situation, die darauf ausgelegt ist, dass es zu so E-Class kommen kann. Natürlich ist auch bemerkenswert, dass Trump das Ganze beendet mit, I think we have seen enough, what do you think, fragt er die Journalisten, great television. Und damit beendet er das Ganze. Also der der der wirkliche Affront liegt ja darin, dass das in der Öffentlichkeit ausgetragen wird. Denn dass Präsidenten so mit anderen Präsidenten sprechen, gerade US-Amerikanische, ist nicht ein Novum, was wir hier erlebt haben. Das Novum ist, dass wir dabei sein konnten. Bojan Panczewski, der ja diese großartigen Recherchen gemacht haben zu den Nord Stream 2 Sprengungen, hat auch zum Beispiel darauf hingewiesen auf Twitter, dass Biden auch 22 mit Zelensky heftig aneinandergerasselt ist, nur hinter verschlossenen Türen. Das hat man dann mal so rausgefunden.
Obama mit den Europäern über dieselben Fragen auch.
Immer wieder geschieht es, was nur nicht auf offener Bühne. Das ist eben das Neue. Wir wissen, Trump versteht sich als Fernsehstar. Und weil du sagst, na ja, Trump ist angeschlagen und so weiter. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass Trump doch hier wirklich strategisch für seine Interessen ziemlich weit vorangekommen ist. Er hat dafür gesorgt, dass es diesen Eklat dann am Ende gibt. Also er hat natürlich dann Zelensky nicht gebremst und dann haben sie sich gegenseitig reingesteigt. Dann kam JD Vans noch dazu und hat das dann noch alles beschleunigt. Aber das hat ja dazu geführt, dass Zelensky dann zu Kirsten Armer gereist ist, dort die anderen EU-Spitzen traf und von denen eigentlich aufgefordert wurde, diesen Brief an Trump zu schreiben. Jetzt scheint Zelensky wieder bald zu Trump zu reisen. Die Europäer haben entsprechend reagiert, indem sie sagen, wie viel Trillionen brauchen wir für die Aufrüstung, die EU, Deutschland. Alle haben darauf jetzt reagiert, auf das, was da vorgefallen ist. Und zugleich bedeutet das ja nicht das Ende der transatlantischen Partnerschaft, denn März ist ein Transatlantika, die gesamte CDU besteht aus Transatlantikern. Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass ja auch viele dieser Milliarden, die jetzt frei gemacht werden, investiert werden in der Form, dass man amerikanische Waffen kauft, was der amerikanischen Volkswirtschaft wieder dienlich sein wird. Also ich sehe, dass Trump fürchterlich agiert, skrupulous ist und alles Mögliche. Ich sehe aber nicht, dass er irgendwie freitret oder so, sondern ich sehe, dass er sehr, sehr selbstbewusst seine Interessen oder die der USA verteidigt.
Also meine Lesart ist ein bisschen anders als deine und sehr anders als die, die wir gerade im Journalismus sehen. Beeindruckend ist ja, dass wir im Krieg zwei kleine Länder haben, die die ganze Welt in Schach halten. Also Russland so groß wie Italien, aber spielt sich auf wie und so weiter. Ja und wir haben jetzt auch immer wieder gehört.
Volkswirtschaftlich meinst du.
Genau, volkswirtschaftlich, aber halt Atomwaffen. Und wir haben jetzt auch gehört, wie hart Putin da geblieben ist. Weil ich stell mir das so und so vor und das sind meine Vorstellungen und Trump hat dann es damit erlined. Die Ukrainer noch kleiner. Also volkswirtschaftlich spielt es gar keine Rolle. Militärisch, auch verloren im Posten sind so krass abhängig von ausländischer Unterstützung, dass man wahrscheinlich in Tagen einfach eine Kapitulation befürchten müsste, wenn da keine Hilfe ist. So und jetzt haben aber beide Länder ganz schön viel rausgeholt für sich jeweils. Also Putin hat es irgendwie geschafft, China auf seine Seite zu ziehen und Nordkoreaner dazu zu bringen, ihre Bevölkerung dahin zu deportieren, damit die da irgendwie als Kanonfutter und so weiter. Und bei der Ukraine ist ja auch sehr beeindruckend, wie weit sie gekommen sind. Der Krieg dauert seit drei Jahren und man sieht null relevante Gebietsbewegung. So wie gelingt das? Also ich habe im Oval Office da einen sehr hilflosen Donald Trump gesehen, der einfach nicht mehr weiter wusste. Und ich habe einen Zelensky gesehen, der einfach in dieses Meeting reinging, genau wusste, um was es da geht. Er wurde ja auch schon begrüßt mit seinem, wie siehst du denn aus, was hast du denn da an und so weiter und so fort. Und dann hat Zelensky so ein offenes Messer hingestellt und dann ist zuerst Trump da reingeflogen und JD Vans ist noch hinterhergesprungen. Zelensky wusste, um was es geht, nämlich diesen Deal. Und ich habe auch schon gesagt, ich bin ein großer Anhänger dieser Stolperdrahttheorie. Also sobald Amerikaner auf ukrainischen Booten sind, sind die sozusagen unantastbar. Auch wenn es zivile Leute sind, die dort als Unternehmer irgendwelche Minen ausbeuten und was auch immer. Eigentlich hätte ich auch gedacht, warum muss Trump jetzt nochmal Sicherheitsversprechen geben? Ist doch völlig klar, wenn dort Bodenschätze ausgeräumt werden von Amerikanern, dann ist das ein automatisches Sicherheitsversprechen. Da sind jetzt Amerikaner, da haben die Russen nichts zu suchen. Und notfalls macht halt Trump dann die große Ansage und gibt einen Befehl. So, er ist ja der Oberbefehlshaber. So, also eigentlich hätte es diese Art von Sicherheitsversprechen.
Ja und Trump sagt doch, er sei Präsident und man könne sich darauf verlassen, dass dann nichts passiert.
Genau.
Also er sagt jetzt ja nicht, welche Sicherheitsgarantien, aber er hat mehrmals in dieser Pressekonferenz gesagt, Sie reden da von anderen Präsidenten. Wenn Putin sich da früher nicht dran gehalten hat, weiß ich nicht, kann sein, da war ich nicht Präsident.
So und jetzt haben wir eine Lage, in der wir zwar alle über Trump jammern, aber diese Argumentation von Trump hat eine inhärente Logik, die bestechend ist, weil wir davon ausgehen können, dass Trump seinen Antlitz nicht verlieren möchte. Er ist am Ende dieser Strongman. Also wenn da Minen in Gefahr sind, weil Amerikaner da keine Profite machen können, dann steht natürlich das amerikanische Militär bereit, stand es ja immer. Also deswegen, das ist ja die zentrale Funktion. So, nun hat sich aber Zelensky nicht darauf eingelassen, sondern hat Chaos verursacht, indem er gesagt hat oder gedacht hat, ich weiß, wie das hier läuft, also da sitzt jetzt der große Fürst der guten Gesellschaft und möchte alles in Interaktion klären. Der trifft mich also locker am Auto, holt mich ab, dann gehen alle nochmal aufs Klo, keiner spricht mit niemanden vorher, da trifft man sich halt da und sagt, ja, coole Minen habt ihr da, den Vertrag, den ihr da ausgabet, der ist ja ganz cool, können wir denen das unterzeichnen. Sagt der eine, nee. Dann sagt sie letztlich einfach, nö mach ich nicht, reicht mir nicht, ich will mehr. So. Und dann lief ein Countdown. Und es war völlig klar, das Ding eskaliert. Und Trump schickt ja auch keine Leute raus, bevor er nicht sein Deal bekommen hat. Also standen die Journalisten alle ewig da. So und dann ging so eine Demütigungswelle los, als ob Zelensky nach drei Jahren Krieg das beeindruckt, auf seine Klamotten angesprochen zu werden.
Das ist ja völlig absurd. Das war natürlich wieder dieser typische Irrsinn.
So und das Ding ist am Ende, klar geendet, es gab diesen Deal nicht. Und Trump stand ohne Deal da. Er konnte natürlich dann den großen Zampano machen und so weiter, aber wir haben doch gesehen, was das für politische Schockwellen in Europa hervorgeholt hat.
Ja, aber dann hat doch Trump immer gesagt, die Europäer sollen sich darum kümmern und jetzt kümmern sich die Europäer dazu. Er hat doch genau das erreicht, hat gesagt, seht hier, ihr könnt euch nicht auf mich verlassen.
Und jetzt haben wir ja dieses große Problem. Mobilisiert eure Milliarden. Genau, das ist doch eine klare Strategie von Schwaben. Also wir haben jetzt dieses Buch von Alex Kaab, der hat ja politische Ideen. Und jedes Mal, wenn er Amerika nennt, heißt es direkt im nächsten Halbsatz und seine europäischen Alliierten. So, die kann man also, wenn man so eine Idee hat, wie wir sie gleich diskutieren, nicht aufs Spiel setzen. So, jetzt haben wir aber Europäer, die sagen, ne, aber Trump, du hast doch immer gesagt, wir sollen uns um unsere eigene Sicherheit kümmern. Und wenn jetzt der französische Präsident kommt und sagt, ja, dann machen wir ein Konjunkturprogramm draus und unterstützen hier unsere Waffentechnologien. Und dann sagen die Deutschen, ja, wir haben auch Waffenthechnologien, wir sind die drittbesten Verbreiterexporteure der Welt. Wir können das auch für uns selber bauen. Wir brauchen nur das Budget. Und es liegt ein Vorschlag auf dem Tisch, den selbst Friedrich Merz als großer Gegner von Staatsverschuldung, kriegt plötzlich 400 Milliarden dafür rausgeleiert. So, das ist nicht im Sinne Amerikas. Und das ist eine Leistung, die Zelensky in einer Interaktion hergestellt hat, der einfach nur gesagt hat, ich weiß, wie eine Interaktion läuft.
Aber machen wir uns doch nichts vor.
Hier sind die Eigenrechte der Interaktion. Also ist ja Lumensediktum. Hier ist die Welt ausgeblendet.
Aber machen wir uns ja nichts vor. Das eine ist ja, dass die USA schon lange wollen, dass Europa mehr aufrüstet und mehr beiträgt.
Aber doch als Alliierte in Amerika kaufen.
Aber das werden sie jetzt auch tun?
Nein, das werden sie nicht tun.
Sie werden in Amerika kaufen?
Nein, das werden sie nicht tun. Also das werden wir sehen, das wird die Entwicklung sein.
Friedrich Merz muss ja noch hinreisen.
Die Gespräche in Europa laufen nicht darauf hinaus, dass man die Gelder, die man jetzt mobilisiert, nach Amerika überweist, um sich amerikanische Wertechnik zu kaufen.
Nicht alles, aber zum Teil wird es wahrscheinlich so sein. Oder zumindest kann sich Amerika auf einen schlanken Fuß damit machen, indem Europa da selbst dann mehr macht.
Der Tipp ist abgefahren, diese Niederlage muss Trump jetzt einstecken.
Ich würde es noch nicht als Niederlage begreifen. Also zum Beispiel Bojan Panczewski schreibt, es geht Trump, er sagt dann aber auch, kann nach einem Telefonat sich natürlich alles wieder ändern, um die globale Einigung mit Russland, dauerhafte Deeskalation, Rückkehr zum Handel, Entschärfung der Spannung mit Moskau, um sich auf China zu konzentrieren. Russland und China so weit wie möglich voneinander trennen. Im Grunde war vieles davon die Politik von Clinton, Bush, Obama, Biden. Das hat aber nicht glänzend bisher funktioniert. Zweitens, Beendigung des Krieges in der Ukraine zu vernünftigen Bedingungen. Die Ukraine ist ein Ärgernis für die US-Regierung und sie will, dass das Problem gelöst wird. Kiev kann damit arbeiten. Mehrere Beamte der beiden Administrationen haben zu Protokoll gegeben, dass eine Endmalitarisierung und die Umwandlung der Ukraine in einen russischen Vasallenstaat nicht einmal diskutiert geschweige denn akzeptiert werden wird.
Aha.
Trump wird es schwer haben, eins und zwei zu bekommen. Dafür gibt es strukturelle Gründe. Also muss er einen anständigen Deal hinbekommen. Welche Animositäten und Spannungen es auch immer geben mag, die USA werden die Ukraine auf keinen Fall im Stich lassen. Auch interessant, es gibt eine Politik und Bemühungen den Krieg zu beenden. Die Regierung Biden steckte ohne Plan in einer Schleife fest. Denn auch das ist ja einfach wahr. Biden hat nichts angeboten außer Waffen, die den Krieg zwar noch weiter durchführbar machen, aber den auch nicht gewinnen lassen oder sonst irgendetwas. Das war, es gibt deshalb, sagt William Panczewski, Gründe für harten realpolitischen Optimismus. Also so sieht, so schätzt er das ein und das ist jetzt nun auch kein Trump-Freund. Was doch klar ist, ist, dass die EU jetzt aufrüstet und Deutschland aufrüstet und all das, um sich stärker einbringen zu können. Aber was ja auch klar sein müsste und manchen Transatlantikern ist es inzwischen auch klar, man wird sich ja nicht mit der EU in einen Zweifrontenkrieg begeben. Man wird ja nicht während Trump beispielsweise jetzt mit Putin verhandelt und mit Zelensky wieder ins Gespräch kommt, den Krieg weiter intensivieren durch Wassmann-Lieferungen. Dass dann irgendein Journalist wie Felix Dachsel oder wie sie alle heißen, schreiben bei Twitter Taurus jetzt, ist ja vollkommen irrsinnig. Damit würde man ja quasi Krieg gegen Russen und auch noch gegen die Interessen der USA führen. Das wird ja nicht der Fall sein. Also wird dieser Krieg in der Ukraine beendet durch eine US-amerikanische Politik, bei der man hoffen kann, dass gewisse europäische Interessen da auch noch vertreten werden. Das kommt dann drauf an, wie gut man verhandeln kann und wie klug sich zum Beispiel Friedrich Merz anstellt. Aber es ist ja keineswegs so, dass das jetzt hier für Trump eine verlorene Sache ist. Und all das, was wir jetzt da gesehen haben, ist zwar an den Bildern und der Stimmung und so einmalig, sowas hat so noch nicht gegeben bei einer Pressekonferenz von Regierungschefs. Aber inhaltlich kann das ja niemanden überraschen, denn das ist ja genau das, was Trump seit Monaten schon weit vor seiner Wahl angekündigt hat. Dass dann jetzt Leute wie zum Beispiel der neue Grünen-Chef Jakob Lase bei Twitter schreiben, wer in dieser Weltlage noch immer zögert, Europas Freiheit auch mit Waffen zu verteidigen, ist nicht links, sondern naiv und unsolidarisch. Da frage ich mich dann schon, naja, die Weltlage ist nämlich erst seit vergangenen Freitag so wie sie ist. Und trotzdem ist ja da die einzig berechtigte Frage, die die Alexander Jorde gestellt hat. Du erinnerst dich der Pfleger, der damals gegen Merkel und Spahn gewettert hat. Er fragte nämlich dann bei Twitter, wann startet deine Grundausbildung Jakob Lase? Wohin er unglaublich viel Kritik bekam und böse beschimpft wurde, wo ich einfach sagen würde, nein, das ist genau die richtige Frage, die zu stellen ist. Denn wenn hier es ja heißt, wer noch zögert, also offenbar zögert ja Jakob Lase noch, der sei unsolidarisch, dann muss man sich ja diese Frage gefallen lassen. Zudem ja jemand wie Alexander Jorde seine Grundausbildung gemacht hat. Und im Übrigen bei der Marine, die haben ja die schönsten Uniformen, wie ich finde, kann also so jemand auf jeden Fall eine solche Frage stellen. Das ist aber jetzt gerade das politische Klima, in dem wir uns befinden und wo man nicht sehen will, dass man nur jetzt mit Trump irgendwie es schaffen muss, dass es nicht ganz so arg ausgeht für die Ukrainer und die Europäer. Aber man wird jetzt nicht mit europäischer Unterstützung Putin besiegen, während Trump irgendwas anderes.
Wir müssen hier also in dem Fall wirklich ganz detailliert vorgehen. Die Ukraine, also nicht die Ukraine, aber die Gebiete, die gerade von Russland besetzt sind und die auch in der russischen Verfassung als russische Gebiete schon aufgenommen sind, die werden entweder an Putin verloren gehen, dann beutet Putin das da aus, oder an die Amerikaner, dann gibt es diese etwas vageren, aber die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen nachgerüstet, auch semantisch Gebiete, also wird es dann Sicherheitsvorkehrungen geben, allein weil der Amerikaner sind. Und sei es, dass man diese Minen, die von Amerikanern ausgebeutet werden und was auch immer, dann durch Waffengewalt nochmal und da reicht es ja völlig.
Es war ja auch immer in der sogenannten dritten Welt so, wenn die Amerikaner dort zugegangen waren.
Die Modelle sind ja sowieso schon seit ewig, also seit längerem jetzt seit dem Irak-Krieg, dass da private Sicherheitsfirmen mit semistaatlichem Auftrag von privaten Firmen angeheuert werden, die dann irgendwelche Steuersubventionen, was auch immer, damit das nicht deren Kosten sind. Also die Ukraine, was das angeht, ist verloren für Europa. Entweder an Trump oder an Putin. Und ich sage jetzt Trump und Putin und nicht Russland und Amerika, weil ich es so meine. Davon unterschieden ist aber die Sicherheitsdiskussion Europas. Ja. Wenn wir eine Befriedung haben, die darauf hinausläuft, dass Putin oder Trump da irgendwelche Ausbeutungsgeschäfte zulässt. So, dann stellt sich für die Europäer die Sicherheitsfrage neu, weil entweder ist der große Treiber, Putin führt jetzt keinen Krieg mehr, also rüstet er gerade aus, bereitet sich vor, also müssen wir uns auch vorbereiten. Oder wir können nie wieder den Amerikanern vertrauen, weil nicht nur jetzt unter Trump ist offensichtlich was passiert, sondern die Stimmung war auch unter Obama und unter Biden so. Sie bricht jetzt nur durch Trump aus. Aber wir haben eine langfristige Entkopplung von Amerika. So. Und ich bin sehr davon überzeugt, dass wir zum einen einen neuen europäischen Aufrüstungsdiskurs dahin gehen kriegen, dass Deutschland jetzt 400 Milliarden mobilisiert, Frankreich nochmal 200 Milliarden, die Briten da wieder groß eingebunden werden. Das Dahmer und seine Nachfolger dann auch wieder an den EU-Gipfeln teilnehmen, weil da auch demnächst über Wer und so weiter diskutiert wird. So, das ist aber nochmal eine eigene Diskussion. Also da rede ich über KI, Maschinen, Wehrtechnik und so weiter. Die Werbpflichtsdiskussion.
Die machen wir jetzt gleich.
Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt in Deutschland. Ich bleibe dabei.
Lass mich nur da anknüpfen.
Also demografisch gesehen ist die Diskussion erledigt.
Stefan, ich wünsche mir nichts mehr, als dass du Recht hast. Marc Schiritz, den ich eigentlich als Transatlantiker im Kopfe hatte, schrieb im Zuge dessen, was im Weißen Haus geschah, etwas sehr interessantes auf Twitter. Er sagte, ein globales Bündnis gegen die USA ist die letzte Chance des Westens. China muss Teil dieses Bündnisses sein und das finde ich erst mal verrückt und dann fand ich es aber interessant und dann fand ich es sogar vielleicht sehr klug. Denn es ist ja so, wir haben jetzt diese NATO und all das und das wird jetzt erst mal noch so bleiben. Also ich glaube, es ist auch jetzt nicht viel geworden, wenn man jetzt einfach sagt, wir gehen nach raus und so weiter. Die Sache ist nur folgende, wenn es wirklich so ist, dass die USA und das gibt es ja durchaus auch von demokratischer Seite, diese Idee haben, Adam Tewes hat ja davor häufig gewarnt, China sogar in eine schießende Auseinandersetzung, sprich in einen Krieg zu verwickeln, weil man nicht haben will, dass da eine andere Welt macht, genauso stark ist oder stärker. Dann Gnade uns Gott, da sind wir wirklich verloren. Insofern zu überlegen, ob China, gerade weil da umweltpolitisch so viel passiert, nicht doch ein Partner sein könnte, nicht mit dem wir alle Werte teilen, aber mit wem teilen wir im Westen schon noch alle Werte, wenn wir an unsere Postfaschisten und so weiter denken. Dann ist vielleicht diese Idee, die Schiritz hier artikuliert, gar nicht blöde, auch wenn sie sehr utopisch erscheint. Zumindest würde sie einmal uns Europäer dazu bringen, aus dieser Block-Konfrontation, die da von Amerika so sehr forciert wird, hinauszutreten und zu denken, wie können wir eigentlich wieder uns assoziieren mit anderen. Denn es kann ja nicht hinauslaufen auf eine Welt, in der wir nur noch Blöcke haben und wählen können, mit wem wir gerade Krieg führen wollen. Trump, Putin oder Xi. Diese Kriege werden wir jedenfalls alle verlieren.
Als Soziologe ist mir nicht fremd, dass eine Beschreibung von Realität, wie sie in der Zeitung steht, eigentlich nur aktualisiert, wie es längst ist. Und das ist in dem Fall so. Als es hieß, okay, es gibt jetzt irgendwie Zölle und die 800 Dollar Grenze für Importe, greift nicht mehr, das heißt, die ganzen Mädels können ihre Schiensachen nicht mehr bestellen. US Postal Service liefert keine Pakete mehr aus, was bedeutet, pro Jahr sind es 1,5 Milliarden Pakete, die aus China auf diesem Wege nach Amerika geliefert werden, die liegen jetzt beim Zoll rum, müssen wieder zurückgeschickt werden. So 1,5 Milliarden, wir hören das so und denken, wow, das ist aber viel. Aus China werden 4,5 Milliarden solcher Pakete nach Europa geliefert. So, wir haben Eisenbahnstrecken, wo kilometerlange Züge bis nach Duisburg durchfahren. Ja. So, wir haben einen Gesprächszusammenhang, der für die Tagesschau immer noch läuft, wie sich Richard David Brecht, der darüber lustig macht, dass auch die Menschenrechte angesprochen wurden und dann wurde da irgendwer besucht, wobei dieser Besuch schon gar nicht mehr stattfindet, jetzt werden nur noch die Menschenrechte angesprochen. Also dieser Blog aus China und Europa, der ist längst gegeben, wirtschaftlich auf jeden Fall. Dieser Wirtschaftsraum ist so eng beieinander, so abhängig voneinander. 90 Prozent unserer Weihnachtsgeschenke, unseren Weihnachtsbaum und damit die Lebensfreude in der dunklen Jahreszeit hängt davon ab, ob es in China ordentlich läuft. Und wir sind eben auch in einer Schicksalsgemeinschaft.
Aber weiß Ursula von der Leyen das auch?
Ursula von der Leyen weiß das sehr.
Aber dann hätte sie nicht diese Zölle unbedingt machen wollen. Ursula von der Leyen hat ja diesen beiden Anti-China-Kurs mitgetragen. Also Biden hat ja diesen Anti-China-Kurs von Trump übernommen. Und Ursula von der Leyen sagte, wunderbar, dann machen wir mit. Und das war ja auch etwas, was Adam Tuos kritisiert hat. Was aber auch unterstützt wurde von der Bundesregierung, zumindest vom grünen Teil der Bundesregierung. Und zum Teil auch von der FDP. Und da ist ja doch interessant, dass man jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr den Partner in Crime in den USA sieht. Und man tatsächlich dazu übergehen könnte, wie Shiritz das ausformuliert und wie du das jetzt gerade nochmal ganz plastisch gemacht hast mit den Geschenken. Dass man doch sieht, dass man eigentlich mehr aneinander hat. Und das ist, um das hier nicht irgendwie zu relativieren. Natürlich ist jetzt China nicht das präferierte Modell für uns, dass wir sagen, so müssen wir auch werden. Nur wir können gleich mal gucken, wie USA auch sein könnte unter Alexander Kaab. Und dann fragen wir uns, wo ist der Unterschied beziehungsweise ist uns vielleicht sogar doch China lieber?
Ich will mal, ich mach jetzt einen Brückenschlag, der ist, also ich mach eine Vermutung. Aber auf der einen Seite weiß ich genau wovon ich rede, auf der anderen Seite halt nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie die EU-Kommission gerade mit der chinesischen kommunistischen Partei kommuniziert. Niemand weiß das. Aber ich weiß, wie die SPD und der DGB immer miteinander kommuniziert haben, wenn es hieß, die SPD muss ja mal einen Vorschlag machen zum Koalitionsfrieden, dass die Arbeitnehmerrechte und so weiter. Dann schreibt man erst mal, kündigt man sich an, sagt, wir brauchen mal einen Termin. So, dann sitzt der SPD-Vorsitzende und der DGB-Chef da und überlegen, okay, dann machen wir das so. Du sagst morgens im Deutschlandfunk das und dann reagier ich neun Uhr mit einer Pressemitteilung so und dann gehst du in die Fraktion und sagst das und dann 16 Uhr bereite ich mich nur mal darauf vor, den Tagesthemen dann das zu sagen, so ja und dann wird es einfach durchgespielt. So und meine Vermutung ist, wenn die EU-Kommission und die Chinesen jetzt irgendwelche Zeugsachen austarieren müssen, weil es ein Zeitgeist gibt und man mit Trump und so weiter, dann wird das genauso gemacht irgendwie. Das ist, ich sehe jetzt nirgendwo, das ist ja auch, guck mal, Trump kam ins Amt und hat gesagt, ne hier diese Zeugdinger und so weiter, jetzt gibt es alles nicht mehr. Diese Pakete lagen auf den Schiffen und wurden in Amerika einfach nicht so. In Deutschland, in Europa ist es ja so, die EU-Kommission kündigt an, sich jetzt mal das Geschäftsgebaren von Schien anzuschauen. Und dann geht so Zeit ins Land. Und dann kommt die nächste Pressekonferenz. So wir starten jetzt mal Ermittlungen. Wir wissen nicht genau, wann die abgeschlossen sind.
Was ja zum Teil auch richtig ist, das zu machen.
Ja, so macht man halt Politik.
Es geht natürlich auch darum, dass da faire Bedingungen sind und dass zum Teil das da mit Schien nicht alles so glatt läuft. Das ist ja auch völlig klar, dass da nachgeguckt wird. Nur, dass man diese Konfrontation nicht weiter beschleunigt. Interessant ist ja auch, wir haben jetzt gerade so einen Börsendown. Dadurch, dass Trump Zölle verkündet.
Alle seine Gewinne seit Amtsantritt sind verloren gegangen dadurch.
Ja, also das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und wenn man es dann mal vergleicht und die Leute in der Finanzbranche, die vielleicht auch da auf Trump gesetzt haben, tun das ja, die haben das ja im Blick. Man siehe sich den MSCI World an oder den S&P 500. Also S&P 500 beinhaltet die 500 wichtigsten amerikanischen Konzerne. MSCI World hat einen ganz starken Schwerpunkt USA. Alles runtergesackt durch diese Zollpolitik von Trump. Man sieht sich mal eine China-ETF an und wird sehen, der ist aber ganz schön im Plus. Was ist denn da los? Und zwar seit Wochen, Monaten und das ist das Interessante.
Trump hat jetzt 1,5 Trillionen, also das was nach der Billionen kommt, an Wert vernichtet. Es waren zwar die Buchwerte und so, aber die spielen natürlich trotzdem eine Rolle. Ja. Einfach weg.
Und das kann man nicht mit ein paar Steuerleistungen wieder ausgleichen.
Das was Trump da gerade macht ist dumm und ich finde, man sieht jetzt in allen oder in vielen Belagen, dass es ausgereizt ist. Man kann immer nur so und so weit drohen, also drohen kann man immer. Man kann eine Drohung aktualisieren, dann kann man nochmal drohen, die Drohung wieder deutlich machen und so weiter. Aber wenn man sie einmal umsetzt, dann geht es an die Substanz. So und Trump muss die ganze Zeit umsetzen. Der droht dem Kongress nichts an, sondern der muss die wirklich alle einbrauben und verschießt das Pulver für eine, in Anführungszeichen, State of the Union. Das kann er nicht jede Woche machen. Das war es jetzt erstmal. Das war jetzt die große Ansprache. Die nächsten drei Monate ist dann nichts möglich. So, das Pulver ist verschossen. 25% Zölle gegen Kanada, das Pulver ist verschossen. Hier ist nichts mehr zu drohen. Hier muss jetzt austariert werden. Die Leute haben die Hände voll, damit jetzt diese Zettel da auszufüllen. Wenn Trump jetzt nochmal sagt 35%, denken die alle nur auf was für ein Scheißer. So, also überall ist das Pulver verschossen. So und der große Vorteil von Trump, das können wir ja nochmal als Teaser für das Buch sagen, der große Vorteil von Trump ist, dass er dumm ist. Also als Sammelbecken für viele Strömungen gut funktioniert, von denen jeder glaubt, ich setz mich durch. Ich bin Elon Musk, ich brauch kluge, kreative Ausländer, ich setz mich durch. Gleichzeitig haben wir die ganzen Neonazis hinter sich, die sagen gar keine Ausländer, auch nicht die super klugen. Wir brauchen ein Ereignisbildungssystem. Dann ist Jaydee Vance mit irgendso der Peter Thiel Idee und so weiter. Also es sind ganz viele Ideen, die sich da kumulieren. Und eine von diesen Ideen kriegen wir ja in diesem Buch ganz detailliert vorgestellt. Und wir denken die ganze Zeit, wenn das die einzige Idee wäre, die Trump grad durchsetzt, Hut ab. Aber er setzt vier solcher Ideen vor, die sich gegenseitig weh gestehen.
Und dann müssten wir wirklich Angst haben. Dann müssten wir Angst haben, genau.
So, aber dieses Projekt, was wir da detailliert legen, geht nicht ohne Internationalallianz.
Jaja, aber es ist beängstigend, glaube ich, in noch mehrfacher Weise.
Der Plan wandert ja wieder in die Schublade für den nächsten Versuch.
Ja, beziehungsweise glaube ich, dass schon etwas hier ausgesprochen wird, was als Stimmung wirklich im Raum ist und was man auch so in Deutschland finden kann. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht bei irgendwelchen rechten Tech-Analysten oder so, sondern ich glaube, es ist etwas in der Luft und das ist beängstigend und das wird hier in diesem Buch aufgegriffen.
Wir können eine wirklich gefährliche Teaserfrage stellen. Dieses Projekt, du hast ja immer das gedruckte Buch hier, ich guck mal, das sind ja beeindruckende, also auch beeindruckendes Literaturverzeichnis, wirklich sehr ausführlich.
Ja, 200 Seiten Text.
Aber wir haben hier sehr viel Text, so 200 Seiten Text. Was ich mich beim Lesen gefragt hab, warum verschwenden sie dieses gute, in sich schlüssige Projekt, das sie da haben, also für sich gut, für mich nicht. Warum verschwenden sie es mit einer republikanischen Präsidentschaft? Warum binden sie es nicht einem Demokraten ans Bein? Also die Gefahr besteht auch, dass man in Amerika einen Diskurs auslöst, in dem es heißt, die Idee war so gut, leider hat der erste Versuch nicht funktioniert durch Blödheit Trumps, aber sollten wir es nicht mit den Demokraten machen. Und wir wissen, die Shifts sind möglich. Mark Zuckerberg, Elon Musk, das waren alles mal quasi Demokraten, die die Vogue-Agenda und so weiter durchgesetzt haben. Die haben jetzt einen Shift gemacht zu Trump. Die bleiben auch nach Trump und Palantir bleibt ja auch.
Ich glaube, es gibt genügend grüne Parteien, damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur unsere Grünen, die dieses Programm dankbar aufbreiten würden. Und das ist auch das Beängstigen daran. Also es ist eben nicht jetzt so ein verrückter Tech-Analyst und ein paar verrückte Reiche wollen da irgendwas machen. Ich glaube, es geht noch tiefer. Ich war im schönen Österreich in Wien, bin dort aufgetreten mit Jean-Philippe Kindler und Ole und hatte auch noch das Vergnügen durch das Labor eines Physik-Nobelpreisträgers geführt zu werden. Ich habe also mit einem Quanten-Physiker gesprochen und es war so, dass das einen doch sehr demütig macht vor dem, was die Wissenschaft so leisten kann, von dem wie die Welt ist bzw. was sie im Innersten zusammenhält und dass man es doch am Ende vielleicht gar nicht so genau sagen kann, dass wir doch irgendwo wieder einen Schritt in die Metaphysik gehen. Ja, es ist also völlig logisch, dass man diesen Schritt nimmt. Nun bin ich ja schon religiös, deswegen muss ich es nicht erst noch werden, aber es war wirklich hochinteressant zu sehen und für mich ein ganz besonderes Erlebnis. Aber natürlich ist Österreich auch noch was anderes. Da gab es den Opernball ein paar Tage vorher. In der Fernsehübertragung sehen wir hier Miriam Weichse-Braun, die jetzt in so einer Loge in der Staatsoper den Außenminister Alexander Schallenberg interviewt. Und du bist ja ein Verfechter, könnte man sagen, der nuklearen Aufrüstung in Europa oder in Deutschland. Die Österreicher haben es natürlich wieder ganz anders für sich gelöst.
Das ist Österreich und dafür habe ich jetzt sechs Jahre im Ausland gearbeitet. Das ist unser Softpower. Es gibt die Hardpower und wir haben vielleicht keine Atomwaffen, wir haben Wolfgang-Madeus-Mozart.
Die Österreicher machen es einfach mit Mozart. Ist das nicht toll?
Ja, finde ich gut. Das ist, falls man sich fragt, ich hab nicht so lange Po wie studiert, was ist noch meines Softpower? Mozart.
Mozart. Ganz, ganz einfach und es wirkt und tatsächlich überall wird ja Mozart gespielt und gehört. Nochmal ganz kurz zu dieser Wehrpflicht. Es gab einen Kulturzeitbeitrag, in dem kam auch Ole vor, das spielen wir jetzt nicht, aber es gab dort auch eine Frau Professorin Grohe von der Bundeswehruniversität, die mit folgendem Statement in dem Beitrag vorkommt.
Denn im Ernstfall ist die Wehrpflicht kein Gebot, sondern eine Pflicht.
Der Staat muss wehrfähig sein, um sich zu wehren. Diese Wehrfähigkeit stellt er her, indem er seine Bürger heranzieht. Sowas funktioniert nicht auf freien freiwilliger Basis. Das heißt, da muss ein Zwang her. Wir Bürger, Bürgerinnen verteidigen unsere freiheitlich demokratische Gesellschaft gegen Angriffe und Zerstörungen von außen. Und das ist eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Pflicht. Und die darf dann auch von 60-Jährigen verlangt werden, von 18-Jährigen.
Ja.
Und da sagst du einfach, ja so ist es halt.
Zum Glück bin ich alt. Also Amerikaner, die ja die Welt dominieren, der Hegemonen sind, 900 Milliarden, Verteidigungsbudget durchballern, die lösen das auch in eine Werbpflicht. Hab ich irgendwie nicht so ganz mitbekommen, wo die Logik ist.
Ich finde es so interessant, dass sie sagt, es braucht den Zwang und redet dann im nächsten Satz von der Freiheit. Also das ist ja auch das interessante, dass die ganze Zeit die Leute, die so viel von Freiheit reden, laufen und die schon eine Einschränkung darin sehen, wenn eine Steuer erhoben wird oder so, sagen jetzt wird aber meine Freiheit beschnitten, die dann zugleich sagen, naja also bei Militär, also da muss schon ein gewisser Zwang her, da muss schon Ordnung und Disziplin sein. Es ist verrückt, ich finde auch interessant, dass es nicht eine große Rebellion gibt bislang, obwohl diese Pläne hier auf dem Tisch liegen für eine Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht seitens der Eltern. Also ich kriege es nicht so ganz zusammen. Wir haben doch dieses Phänomen Helikoptereltern. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen größer als man denkt, aber es ist ja in der Tat so, dass mir zum Beispiel Lehrer erzählen, sie geben im Aufsatz eine 4, sofort stehen die Eltern auf der Matte, sagen wir können auch noch den Rechtsanwalt mitbringen. Früher hat man auch mal Kinder, wenn sie sich nicht benommen haben im Unterricht vor die Tür gesetzt, dann kommt gleich psychische Schäden, traumatisiert etc. Also wir haben diese hypersensibilisierten Eltern, die aber offenbar überhaupt nicht hypersensibilisiert sind, wenn es um die Wehrpflicht geht.
Nein, ich verstehe nicht warum. Was ist so schwer daran zu beobachten? Die Eltern gehen auf die Matte, wenn das eigene Kind eine 4 hat. Die machen aber keine Demonstrationen vor dem Rathaus gegen Viren allgemein. Wenn der Brief im Briefkasten landet, dann ist die Diskussion fast. Diese Eltern haben die Hände voll. Ich erlebe es doch an mir selber.
Aber du glaubst wirklich, dass dann, wenn die Wehrpflicht da ist, dass es dann Ärger gibt?
Also wenn ich eine Überzeugung habe, dann, dass es nicht möglich ist in Deutschland jemanden einen Brief nach Hause zu schicken, in dem drin steht, dein 18-jähriger Sohn, den du so und so viel zum Musikunterricht, zur Schule, zum was weiß ich, Sport gefahren hast, den brauchen wir morgen in der Kaserne. Vor allem nicht, wenn du den dann da hinbringst, ja und dann da siehst, das ist die Kaserne, dann ist Krieg in Deutschland.
Stefan, mögest du Recht haben?
Bevor wir Deutschland mit einer Wehrpflicht im äußeren verteidigen, ist hier Bürgerkrieg. Das ist wirklich eine ganz feste Überzeugung. Ich habe mich sehr viel mit Familie und Gemützuständen und demografischen Grundlagen und Mangellagen befasst.
Im Zuge unserer Folge hat mir eine Hörerin auch einen Hinweis gegeben im Presseklub. Vom vergangenen Sonntag war unter anderem der Journalist Marc Brost zu Gast, der äußert sich zur Aufrüstung und diesen Sondervermögen wie folgt.
Was ganz schwierig ist und das haben wir eben gesehen seit dem 24. Februar 2022, ist den Menschen zu erklären, warum wir das tun, warum wir die Ukraine verteidigen, wer uns eigentlich angreift. Und da sind wir wieder bei einem Punkt der putinischen Kriegsführung, warum er, da bin ich ja ganz bei Ina Ruck, im Augenblick im Kreml sich das anschauen kann, wie eine Kinoshow. Die Destabilisierung westlicher Demokratien, die innere Zersetzung des Diskurses ist auch ein Teil der russischen hybriden Kriegsführung. Das heißt, diese Veränderung, die wir jetzt erleben, trifft auf ein aufgerautes Land, das nicht nur wegen drei Jahre Ampel gerade mental ein bisschen am Boden ist, sondern man muss wahnsinnig viel erklären, machen und tun. Wir müssen unter Umständen über eine Wehrpflicht reden. Wir müssen darüber reden, ob unsere Kinder wieder tatsächlich dieses Land verteidigen müssen. Das sind alles ganz schwierige Debatten. Mein Sohn ist 17 Jahre, ich möchte auch nicht, dass er in den Krieg ziehen muss. Aber das sind alles Dinge, die wirklich jetzt Führung erfordern und eine große mentale Veränderung. Der Rest ist ehrlich gesagt politische Routine.
Da ist wieder das Wort Führung und da wird also jetzt schon der Journalismus darauf eingeschworen, eine Stimmung herzustellen, bei der dann irgendwann alle einwilligen und sagen, ja es muss aber auch leider sein, mein 17-Jähriger muss auch los.
Journalisten haben in diesem Land nichts mehr zu sagen. Niemand guckt den Presseclub, außer 75-jährige Omis. Wirklich, hier muss man jetzt... wann kriegen denn...
Aber bei Twitter sind es doch auch die Jungen. Hier Jakob Lase und diese jungen Grünen, die sind doch genauso verrückt. Du glaubst doch, wenn du den jungen Grünen jetzt vorlegen solltest, Wehrpflicht einführen, dann würden die doch höchstens noch fragen, ja aber ist das auch gleichberechtigt, damit auch Non-Binäre bei Militär dienen würden? Das wäre doch die einzige Frage, die die noch stellen, um dann einzuwilligen.
Also die letzten jungen Grünen haben als kollektive Entscheidung gesagt, nicht nur diese Partei nicht, sondern dieses System nicht, dass danach eine junge grüne Generation nachgrücken gelassen wird, die natürlich wieder auf den, komm wir machen euch wieder versprechen, ihr seid die Neuen, ihr könnt hier aufsteigen, dass die nachplappern, was sie irgendwo lesen, ja. Aber sorry.
Also Stefan.
Völlig ausgeschlossen. Ich sage es heute und ich habe schon Stefan, ich hoffe. ein paar harte Sachen gesagt. Und die waren auch richtig am Ende.
Ja, ja Stefan, ich wünsche.
Niemand konnte sich vorstellen, dass wir bis März 500 Milliarden Sondervermögen so, außer wir. Wir haben es schon vor Jahren gesagt und jetzt ist jetzt das Moment da und ich sage. Werpflicht kann man diskutieren, so viel man will. Den ersten Brief in den Briefkasten reinstecken, lesen lassen und dann mal gucken, was passiert.
Du bist ja auch bei Threads, da bin ich nicht. Nee, da bin ich nicht.
Ich schicke da nur automatisiert meine stefan-schutz.com-Blog-Artikel.
Aber du hast mir irgendwas von Threads geschickt, das konntest du vielleicht mal vortragen. Das hat mich wahnsinnig gefreut, dass du mich da mit konfrontiert hast.
Ich gehe in meine Meta-Messages um.
Also über Instagram hast du mir einen Screenshot geschickt.
Den trag ich gerne vor, ich weiß grob, worum es geht. Also Paul Ronsheimer schreibt, das Interesse an der außenpolitischen Lage nach dem silenzigen Trump-Eckla und der Anknüpfung des Waffens, Stopps, Stopps ist riesig. Auch bei Podcasts. Piatow und ich haben gestern Nacht aktuell produziert, aus Kiew natürlich, dazu in den vergangenen Tagen Folgen mit und so weiter. Wir wissen ja, Ronsheimer macht ja immer am 13. Tag des Monats den elften Podcast. Und das ist jetzt keine ausgedachte Zahl. Daraufhin nimmt, warte mal, Micky Beisenherz? Nee, das ist ja nicht, ich bin hier im falschen. Ach hier, oh, oh, oh, wir gehen ans Eingemachte. Ich lese vor. Friedemann Karich schreibt, es war eine Falle, um den Verrat der USA an Ukraine und NATO und die Allianz mit Putin zu legitimieren. Es ist aber auch die größte Chance für Europa, sich jetzt zu einem echten Gegengewicht zu vereinen. Und so wird Friedrich Merz noch vor Amtsantritt, der vielleicht wichtigste Politiker der freien Welt. Ich hab dir das aus Gründen geschickt.
Ja, weil ich mich natürlich wahnsinnig darüber freue.
Es war Karneval.
Es war Karneval, ja. Und das ist Karneval.
Das ist Karneval.
Das ist, wenn die Ordnung auf den Kopf gestellt wird. Ja, siehst du, da vielleicht Friedrich Merz gesagt, für den würde ich aber schon kämpfen wollen für die freie Welt.
Ja, Friedrich Merz ist ja nicht so blöde, die 500 Milliarden jetzt schon wieder mit irgendwelchen Bürgergeldverrechnungen zu machen. Ja, ja. Söder sekundiert das auf der Aschermittwochsgüne und so.
Das ist unsere freie Welt. Für die werden wir gemeinsam mit Friedemann Karich kämpfen.
Was haben wir bei der Impfpflicht immer gesagt? Bei der Impfpflicht haben wir irgendwann festgestellt, nachdem es da plötzlich so zur Diskussion gab, ah, da gibt es so Leute, die nutzen jetzt die Gelegenheit, um dem Staat zu sagen, du hast nie etwas für mich getan, also tu ich nichts für dich. Ist es egal, was du von mir wählst, in dem Fall ist es eine Impfung, kriegst du nicht. So, das ist der Modus. Und die Leute gucken nicht Presseclub und lassen sich dann irgendwie, und der Merz ist jetzt der Führer der freien Welt und übrigens auch dein Bundeskanzler.
Ja, ich hab dann gedacht, wie kann man sagen, das ist jetzt irgendwie der Mann der freien Welt und so was, und dann hab ich gedacht, irgendwie geht das doch gar nicht so alles überein, oder? Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, dass du mir das schicktest. Ich hör mal kurz rein. Es gibt in den Senden, den mit Samira El-Wassil und Friedemann Karich, diesen Piraten-Sender Powerplay-Podcast. Und dann reden die da tatsächlich über Friedrich Merz. Und ich habe jetzt einfach mal so einen längeren Clip, der geht eigentlich noch viel, viel länger, in dem Friedemann Karich, bevor er das geschrieben hat, über Friedrich Merz redet. Und dann können wir uns ja noch mal fragen, ob es zwei Friedemann Karichs gibt oder zwei Friedrich Merz. Das ist eigentlich die Frage, die man sich da stellt.
Eins muss man Friedrich Merz wirklich lassen. Er ist der konsequenteste Kanzler, den man sich für Deutschland gerade vorstellen kann. Weil er, finde ich, alles das, was ich an Deutschland nicht mag, in sich vereint. Also er ist ein aufbrausender Seriositätsdarsteller, der einerseits mit großer Geste im November einen fairen Wahlkampf und eine Abgrenzung nach rechts verspricht und bald es super lässig bricht, sobald es ihm irgendwie zu nützen scheint. Der ist nie bereit, sich zu korrigieren und an meinen Fehler zuzugeben, aber immer bereit für unfaire Attacken gegen seine Gegner, gegen Arme, gegen anders Aussehende und Andersdenkende, wie jetzt eben mit dieser Anfrage. Der ist diese Attitüde, solange ihr eure Füße unter meine Bundesrepublik stellt, das ist er auf zwei Beinen und einer Haarinsel. Das ist jemand, der sich durch hochdotierte Mandate, Wirtschaftskompetenz selber zuspricht, was auch so deutsch ist und nicht checkt, dass das eigentlich nur ein großer Ausdruck seiner Privilegien ist. Er ist ein Dampfplauderer und Wichtig-Tur, der immer irgendwo was zu melden haben muss, der pathetisch mit seinem Gewissen argumentiert, um seinen eigentlich grenzenlosen Opportunismus zu überspielen. Und dann drei Wochen später, als alle anderen längst eingesehen haben, dass er mit seinen angeblich vom Gewissen getriebenen Forderungen in der Migrationspolitik komplett daneben lag, die Position dann räumt. Aber ohne das wirklich zuzugeben, das könnte natürlich jemand wie Friedrich Merz, wie der typische Deutsche nicht. Er hört sich gerne reden, wäre gerne volksnah, hat aber eigentlich glaube ich so große Angst vor Menschen, dass er lieber den Privatflieger nimmt als mal die Bahn. Er ist rechts offen und hat Angst vor links, weil er es nicht versteht und schon gar nicht, was an Recht so schlimm ist, weil es ihn ja persönlich nicht bedrohen würde. Ich glaube, Friedrich Merz hält es auch für ein politisches Talent, die Leute im Zweifel schamlos anzulügen. Und gesteht sich das auch alles selbstgerecht glaube ich zu, aus der Kränkung heraus, gegen eine Frau verloren zu haben, was auch so unfassbar deutsch ist.
Ja und dann können wir uns ja nochmal überfragen, ob das jetzt der tolle Anführer der freien Welt ist. Kann jeder für sich selbst beantworten. Und wir leiten über zu dem Buch.
Ich halte übrigens Friedrich Merz auch für einen Loser einfach. Also wirklich mit 28,5 Prozent.
Ja das ist ja überhaupt kein tolles Ergebnis.
Das ist einfach katastrophal. Das ist so schlecht. Und da kann man sich froh sein, wenn man überhaupt eine Bundestagsmeerheit zusammenkriegt, um den Kanzlerposten zu haben. Aber danach müssen eigentlich die Tore offen stehen für, ich mache ja mal Koalitionsfrieden und na klar mache ich Zugeständnisse und überhaupt und so.
Er war ja bei dieser Bildgala, wir haben ja ausführlich darüber gesprochen und hatte dort doch erst seine Spendenhöhe daran knüpfen wollen, wie erfolgreich die CDU abschneidet. Und da sprach er ja von 40 Prozent.
Es ist einfach absurd.
Davon ist er sehr weit entfernt.
Wir müssen uns jetzt trauen, die Loser auch als Loser zu beobachten. Wir können nicht immer die ganze Zeit, oh ich hab so Angst vor Trump, weil der hat ja Atomwaffen und so. Trump ist ein Loser, Merz ist ein Loser, das sind alles Loser.
Kämpfen für Friedrich Merz ist wirklich keine gute Idee. Wir sprechen jetzt über dieses wirklich spektakuläre Buch, The Technological Republic, Hard Power, Soft Belief and the Future of the West von Alexander C. Karp und Nicolas W. Samiski. Sie, Samiska, sie beide sind von Palantir und legen uns ihre Vision ganz offen da. Eigentlich eine Dystopie, für sie ist das eine Utopie. Wir müssen darüber ausführlich reden. Ich habe mich aufgrund dieser Lektüre dann entschlossen, doch noch mit dem Manifest des Una-Bombas zu warten für den nächsten Monat, weil ich nicht noch was Gruseliges lesen wollte, sondern habe dann als Gegengift, wenn man so möchte, Y2K gelesen. Hast du vielleicht schon gehört von Colette Shade, eine Journalistin, How the 2000s became everything? Sie erzählt also die Geschichte, die popkulturelle, digitale und ein bisschen auch die politische Geschichte der 2000er Jahre und zeigt, wie sich alles so veränderte und was uns davon heute noch prägt. Ein kurzweiliges Buch, ein Buch, das eben nicht so dystopisch auf die Welt blickt und gerade nicht auf diese Konsumerkultur, die Alexander Kaab so sehr abstraft. Außerdem ist zur richtigen Zeit ein kurzer Roman erschienen von Lucas Maisel. Der beschäftigt sich mit dem Mann, der damals nichts tat, der damals oder das richtige Tat, in dem er nichts tat, der nämlich als ein Alarm angezeigt wurde, nicht darauf reagierte und sagte, das kann nur ein Fehlalarm sein. Wir können hier nicht von der Sowjetunion jetzt davon ausgehen, dass die Amerikaner das Atomprogramm gezündet haben. Und damit hat er tatsächlich das Ende der Welt verhindert. Und da gibt es einen kurzen Romanzo, den sollte man jetzt unbedingt lesen. Außerdem gibt es noch von mir Musik, diesmal Benjamin Britten, aus der FAZ einen kurzen Bericht über die Rekrutierer in der Ukraine und das brutale Vorgehen und ein Artikel über einen Ring, mit dem sich Paare gegenseitig überwachen können.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich habe auch eine Anti-Dote oder wie das heißt, ein Gegenentwurf zu Alex Karp, denn die Direktorin des Bundesinstituts für Bevölkerungsforschung, klingt natürlich gleich super sexy, Katharina Spieß hat einen der im Wirtschaftsdienst einer, das ist natürlich Special Interest, ich habe einen Hörerhinweis dazu bekommen. Zum Thema Förderung der frühen Bildung und in alternden Gesellschaften, worüber man so nachdenken muss, brauchen wir ein Bundesprogramm für Kitas. Ich möchte gern vorher schon sagen, das ist viel näher dran an der Werbpflichtsdiskussion, wenn man sie ernsthaft über Verteidigungsfähigkeit, Willigkeit und gibt es eigentlich was zu verteidigen, führen möchte er, dann sollte man in diese Richtung denken. Dann stelle ich zwei Texte gegenüber. Zum einen hat Kevin Roos in der New York Times darüber geschrieben, wie es ist, jetzt ohne Coding-Kenntnisse Code zu produzieren, Software herzustellen durch KI-Hilfe. Und in seinem Marcus On AI Newsletter hat der ehemalige Professor für Psychologie und eben heute KI-Unternehmer selbst, Markus, soll ich seinen Nachnamen nicht, naja, jedenfalls, Markus, Gary Markus heißt er, so heißt er, eine Antwort darauf geschrieben, wo die Gefahren liegen. Kleine individuelle Vorteile, klar, die sind da, aber haben das ja vielleicht auch mit großen Problemen zu tun. Und dann hat Philipp Hopf in seinem Hopf und Hate Podcast über sein Lieblingsbuch gesprochen. Ich habe Claude danach gefragt, was hat es mit dem Buch auf sich? Wir gehen Claudes Antworten durch und schauen in einen Text von Anne Applebaum. Sie hat im The Atlantic über den neuen Amerikaner gesprochen. Den brutalen Amerikaner, wie er uns gezeigt wurde. Denn der ist ja gar nicht so neu. Er hat jetzt nur die Vorderbühne betreten. Da gibt es so ein paar Sachen, über die wir mal nachdenken müssen. Und außerdem finde ich das aus akademischen Kniffen ein sehr guten Text. Wir haben sie ja sehr kritisiert für ihren... Klar, sie hat die Gelegenheit genutzt. Wir müssten eigentlich auch das Auswahlkomitee kritisieren dafür, überhaupt einen Applebaum Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchhandels zu geben. Aber es sind nun mal kriegerische Zeiten und ein paar Gedankengänge sind ja gar nicht so schlecht. Also gehen wir einem nach, den ich gut finde.
Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Ich will noch darauf hinweisen, dass ich in diesem Monat in Duisburg und in Reutlingen zu Gast bin. Das findet man alles auf meiner Homepage www.wolffgangm.schmidt.de Sehr gut.
Ich habe auch zwei Termine im April fürs Buch. Einen Karlsruher, einen in Wien. Ich hab's noch nicht auf der Webseite eingetragen, aber werde ich jetzt die Tage machen.
Und in den Salon kommt man ganz einfach. Man geht auf neu20er.de. Das ist auch die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen und geht dann auf den goldenen Button. Dann kommt man zu Steady und ab drei Euro im Monat kann man dann den Salon abonnieren und kann natürlich auch alle alten Folgen hören. Also es sind Dutzende Bücher, Hunderte Bücher sind es inzwischen, bei die wir gemeinsam oder auch einzeln gesprochen haben, die wir empfohlen haben. Viele Texte auch zum Silicon Valley, um das es ja heute wieder gehen wird. Es ist natürlich auch möglich diesen Salon über Patreon zu abonnieren oder auch über Apple ist das ganz einfach mit einem Klick möglich.
Genau, wir haben eine Präferenz für Steady, weil wir bei Steady zum Beispiel dieses vor dem Salon, im Salon, alles in einem rutsch als eine Datei zur Verfügung stellen. Das ist für sehr viele sehr einfacher. Und bei Steady gibt es den Salon und den Podcast, also ab sofort alles komplett vollständig bei Steady. Für Patreon wird es weiter geteilt sein. Also bucht man normal Patreon, kriegt dort den Salon und muss den Rest über den öffentlichen Feed hören. Bei Apple ist ja sowieso alles miteinander verschränkt. Das ist ja da sehr praktisch.
Wunderbar. Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich.